[Music]
foreign
welcome back everybody so we've been
talking about how to solve these systems
of linear differential equations using
eigenvalues and eigenvectors
and now I'm going to show you one of my
favorite uh versions of this system
which we call a saddle point
so if the a matrix has this form one
zero zero minus one we're going to call
this a saddle
and I actually don't even need to
compute the eigenvalues and eigenvectors
of this Matrix because it's already
diagonal okay so this is we don't need
the T and the D and the T because this
Matrix is already diagonal
and since it's already diagonal
we know for example that the eigenvalues
of this a matrix are just the diagonal
entries so for example you know Lambda
the lambdas are going to be plus and
minus one the eigenvalues of this system
are going to be plus and minus one and
so the building blocks of my Dynamics
are going to be things like you know e
to the plus T and e to the minus t
Solutions okay and since this is
diagonal we can kind of just write down
the solution and write down and draw the
picture kind of the phase portrait of
what trajectories look like in this
system
and I'll give you a bunch of examples of
systems that have these Dynamics this is
actually one of the most prevalent types
of Dynamics for physical systems so if
you think about an inverted pendulum
that's unstable it's going to have this
linearization it's going to look like
this for small angles
me as a human Walker is approximately an
unstable pendulum I'm feeling kind of
stable today mostly stable but in
general you know we are unstable pendula
and so our local linear small angle
Dynamics are going to look like this
these crop up all over the place these
exist as fixed points in the solar
system so we just sent the James Webb
Space Telescope to a point in the solar
system that has these local Dynamics so
that'll be kind of cool I'll show you
all those examples but let's write down
the solution here
and so I'm just going to uh be very
explicit by what I mean by this
differential equation and maybe I'll do
this in green because it'll look cool so
I have uh DDT
and this Vector X let's say it has a
component X and Y
and you know sometimes I overload
notation I'm notorious about doing this
I always overload my notation so bold x
with an underbar is a vector and it
contains two components Little X and
little y the X component and the Y
component and I hope you're okay with
the fact that this little X is just one
of the components of this Vector X okay
sometimes I would call this X1 and X2
but I just want you to be comfortable
with different ways of writing notation
kind of this is what you call an abuse
of notation we're abusing our notation
but it's okay
and so DX DT and dydt equals this Matrix
system one zero zero minus one one zero
zero minus one
times uh X and Y
and again because this is already
diagonal I can just write down the
Matrix solution I can take the Matrix
exponential of this easily and I can
write down
that X of t
and Y of T my you know my my state at
time T is going to equal
e to the positive T
0 0
e to the negative t
times my initial conditions X naught and
Y naught
you say why not I can give you a million
reasons why not
and what this means is that these again
are completely diagonal and decoupled so
X of T essentially what this means is
that you know X of T equals e to the t x
naught and Y of T equals e to the minus
t y naught so the X direction is
massively unstable if I start with a
little X naught it's going to blow up
you know and go off to infinity and grow
and grow and grow and if I start with a
little y naught a little initial
condition in the y direction it's going
to Decay to zero because this is a
stable e to the minus t and so we can
draw this phase portrait this is called
a saddle point
um this is called a
saddle
point and I'll tell you why it's called
a saddle in a minute it's kind of
literally like if you drop a marble on a
saddle it'll have these Dynamics I'm
about to show you a lot of the naming
and math is kind of old fashioned I
think it's funny that you know there's
an algorithm in statistics called the
lasso this is called a saddle point you
know there are horse shoe orbits so kind
of all of this old tiny cowboy stuff
crops up in in the naming and so I'm
going to draw this thing
again in the uh X
Y coordinates and my X and Y coordinates
and it's kind of exactly like what I
just told you so um if I start with an
initial condition that has only an X
naught and Y naught is zero so I start
with some initial condition you know
here or here so Y is zero but I start
with some X naught these are going to
grow without bounds because e to the
plus T is unstable so I'm going to draw
a plus kind of that's ugly I'm going to
draw an unstable arrow in the X
Direction kind of if I start with
positive X it's going to become more and
more and more positive if I start with a
Negative X it's going to become more and
more and more negative it's going to be
unstable in x
and similarly if I start with a little
initial condition in y
either of these but 0x if I start
exactly on this y-axis these Dynamics
are going to be stable and they're going
to contract so a little y naught is
going to get smaller and smaller and
smaller as time goes on
and so these arrows are going to be
pointing inward
and so the x-axis and the y-axis for
this problem are in fact the
eigenvectors of this Matrix because it's
already diagonal so the eigenvector
corresponding to this eigenvalue one is
the X Direction the eigenvector
corresponding to this eigenvalue
negative one the stable eigenvalue is
the y direction and so if I start
exactly on that x-axis I will stay on
that x-axis and grow without bound if I
start exactly on that y-axis I will stay
on that y-axis and my trajectory will
shrink to the origin
um again we have a fixed point at the
origin if we started exactly at x equals
zero we'll stay at x equals zero because
a times zero is zero and so D DT of X
would be zero at that point no force is
pushing me one way or the other
it's really interesting is looking at
what happens you know if I take some
initial condition that's not on one of
these axes let's say I take an initial
condition here
what's going to happen is in the the Y
component of this is going to shrink and
shrink and shrink and shrink and shrink
and it's going to keep shrinking forever
because it's completely decoupled if any
the Y component is always going to get
smaller and smaller but at the same time
maybe I'll start over here at the same
time the X component is going to grow
and grow and grow and grow exponentially
and so I get trajectories that kind of
shrink in the y direction as they grow
in the X Direction and over here since
this had a Negative X naught it's going
to shrink in the y direction and again X
is going to get bigger and bigger and
bigger in that negative Direction
so I have these kinds of orbits here
similarly down here Y is going to get
smaller while X increases
down here Y is going to get smaller
while X increases okay and so this is
what the phase portrait
of a saddle generically is going to look
like
it's going to have everything kind of
compressing in One Direction and
stretching out in the other direction
okay which is kind of cool this is
almost like if you were making Taffy
you'd be you know pulling that tap you
would get thinner in One Direction and
longer in the other direction so people
actually model mixing and stretching and
folding using Saddle Point Dynamics and
things like that so this is the kind of
pretty picture you get for for saddle
Dynamics where you have one unstable
Direction and One stable Direction
anytime your system has any unstable
directions at all even a single unstable
Direction means your system is unstable
so a saddle point is in fact unstable
so maybe I'm not as stable as I thought
I was
um
and this is a very very important uh
fixed point or type of dynamical system
that's going to come up a lot
so I'm calling these dynamical systems
because they change in time x dot means
DX DT how X changes in time so this is
literally the path I would take in time
if I started with this initial condition
I'd flow forward in time okay one of the
cool things about Saddles is if I
reverse time they are still Saddles if I
reversed all of these arrows it would
just change which of X and Y is stable
and unstable but the it's still a saddle
point
um
something that's kind of neat that I'm
going to show you in the next few
lectures not the next one but but
probably the one after that is that even
though we're looking at very idealized
linear systems and we know that most of
the real world is not linear like the
pendulum right like a pendulum swinging
is only linear for very small angle
approximations but for large angles it's
non-linear
um you know Theta double dot equals
minus sine of theta and sine of theta is
a nonlinear function most of the systems
we care about are actually non-linear
the the astrophysics planetary problems
that's non-linear physics
but there exists these fixed points like
this one here where x dot so if maybe x
dot equals some generic non-linear
system f of x where this is not linear
it's not a matrix times x maybe it's x
squared and it has cubic terms and it's
nastier Sines of x
but there are often fixed points
fixed points
where f of x equals zero and so what you
can do in these systems is you can kind
of zoom in near that fixed point the
Dynamics are going to locally look
linear and they're going to have these
kind of canonical behaviors they're
going to either be saddles or sources or
spirals or I'm going to show you all of
the kind of types and menagerie of fixed
points that you can have at least in two
dimensions and we're going to use those
as building blocks even in very
non-linear systems you're going to be
able to piece together kind of the
geometry of that phase space of how
trajectories move in these uh you know X
and Y coordinates based on kind of
understanding these these these building
blocks these you know saddle points and
Center points and stable points and
things like that okay so that's all
coming up and a saddle is a really
really important one of these Okay so
I'll give you a couple of other examples
let me
pick a couple of colors here so some
examples of Saddle points that I like
examples
of Saddle points
or examples of systems that have these
saddle fixed points that's more what I
mean these are going to be non-linear
systems but some of the fixed points are
going to have this local saddle behavior
that if you zoomed in there would be an
unstable and a stable Direction
uh so I already told you one of my
favorite examples is you know
um
a person walking uh maybe they're
dancing I don't know but if you think
about it so you can't see my legs but
I'm standing on my tippy toes so I can
feel unstable and if you like shot
novocaine into my ankles I would be
pretty upset and I'd fall over because I
am an unstable kind of like a like a
pendulum right like so you have a
pendulum in a stable position it just
swings down but you could bring that
pendulum up into the upright position
and if you balance like a broom on your
hand that's an unstable pendulum and
that has these saddle Dynamics and a
human this is you know I've drawn him
standing you know I've drawn them
standing in a very stable position but
if you stood on one foot maybe maybe I
can do this better if I stand on one
foot
that's better that's much better then on
that one foot I'm much more uh like a
saddle point because I have this kind of
fundamental instability that if you kick
me a little bit in One Direction I'm
going to accelerate in that direction
and go unstable okay at least locally
that's that's going to be true
[Music]
um
and actually you can you can you can
think about this as
um your arms are kind of the stable
Direction when you're walking in an
efficient gate your arms are actually
stable if I just do this they're not
going to blow up to Infinity they're
stable and eventually they'll die out
but the the body part and your legs
that's this unstable direction that if
you kicked yourself you'd go unstable
and a theme in differential equations
and dynamical systems is that having a
little bit of instability is actually
very good for efficient maneuverability
so if you think about how we walk as as
humans bipedal uh walkers
all I have to do to move forward is kick
myself a tiny bit in my unstable
Direction I just lift up one foot and I
go a tiny bit in that direction and
gravity takes care of the rest it moves
me a lot in that direction and then I
put my foot down and I kick myself a
little bit in the unstable Direction
with my other foot and so very very
efficiently I can harness this kind of
unstable direction to get a lot of
forward motion for cheap okay this is
actually how fighter jets
turn so efficiently is that they're kind
of natively unstable and they use
control systems to to just barely
stabilize themselves so that they can
turn on a dime so so these saddle points
if you think about it if I wanted to
have really energy efficient control
I want to be kind of just on one side of
a saddle point because if I'm right here
if I'm right here and I kick myself a
tiny bit to the left or a tiny bit to
the right I spend a tiny tiny little bit
of energy I can go to completely
different
locations so I get a large kind of gain
for a small input in these saddle type
systems that's how humans walk very
efficiently that's how planes fighter
planes turn very efficiently so that's
kind of cool that's one example is a
person walking
person walking and I like to say that
this is you know efficient Locomotion
efficient
locomotion
good that's one
and a second one that I like to talk
about is why it's actually called a
saddle point in the first place is
because you can imagine I'm going to
have a really hard time drawing a saddle
but you can picture a saddle that you
would put on a horse
and the saddle that you would put on a
horse
has a part here that goes up so this is
kind of where your butt goes and this is
the pommel that's called the pommel of
the saddle
where you hold on and then on either
side it kind of drops off and I'll draw
this one back here okay so this is kind
of like the saddle you would put on a
horse this is why this is called a
saddle point and if you picture putting
a bead or a marble on the saddle and
rolling it it kind of behaves the way
that this would behave so at least
locally if I perfectly lined my marble
up so it was exactly on this Ridge kind
of here it would actually be stable in
this direction
it would it would approach you know kind
of the center
um and if there was a little friction it
would eventually die out this is an
idealization of course it's not actually
going to do that but if I started my
bead sorry I should be down here if I
started my bead down here
um on this kind of stable Direction it
would kind of just slowly eventually die
out at that at that point
but if I kicked it a little bit off in
this kind of unstable saddle Direction
where your legs go then it's going to
roll off and go to Infinity to hit the
ground okay and so this is why this is
called a saddle because a saddle kind of
if I dropped a bead on it it has one
stable Direction and One unstable
Direction where you know if I roll it
and this way it falls off if I roll it
in this way it kind of stays put okay
that that's why this is called a saddle
now funny uh you might ask is that there
is actually something called a monkey
saddle in dynamical systems which I
really like which is a saddle but
it still has a place for your legs
here and it still has a pommel Pomo a
pommel
but it has a place for the monkey's tail
so instead of the back going up this is
kind of like a cubic function and it has
a place for the monkey's tail this is
called a monkey saddle
I don't know I'm telling you this I just
find it fascinating okay so that's
another interesting example is an actual
you know bead on a saddle like a marble
on a saddle sometimes I'm going to call
this a bead by bead I mean a marble or
something that rolls or slips with no
friction a bead on an actual saddle
a saddle like the saddle you'd put on a
horse
my absolute fate examples of this the
one that kind of got me really inspired
one of my first research projects as a
you know freshman undergraduate at
Caltech was this problem of planetary
Dynamics
planetary
Dynamics and I've been actually very
fortunate to have learned like this
dynamical systems material is some of my
favorite stuff you know eigenvalues and
eigenvectors and fixed points and phase
portraits you can tell I love this I've
been doing this again since I was an
undergraduate I've had the pleasure of
learning this from some amazing people
like Jerry Marsden and Wang sancoon were
my instructors I learned a lot from Sean
shadden and Shane Ross later on I
learned from Phil Holmes so it's you
know really been amazing to kind of soak
up that Knowledge from those excellent
people and I like love sharing it with
you so you know I'm hoping a lot of what
they taught me comes through in these
lectures
and when I was an undergrad working with
with Jerry Marsden and Wang sancoon it
was a really exciting time
because people were so so planetary
Dynamics like how you know moons orbit
planets and how the planets orbit the
Sun and predicting the motion of all of
these celestial bodies that's been
something that's fascinated uh humans
since before written history okay like
for all of history people have looked up
at the sky and wondered why planets do
the things they do we name our Gods
after planets and our planets after Gods
because planets do cool stuff that's
unpredictable and chaotic
and in the kind of early 2000s there
started to become some really new
Machinery being developed some new
mathematical Machinery to understand
energy efficient transportation in the
solar system and so I'll tell you just
kind of a teaser story about that that I
thought was really cool so we have the
Sun
and I'll try my best to make it sun
colored so this is the sun it's awesome
and let's say we have Jupiter okay I'm
going to make Jupiter uh what color
should I make Jupiter why not uh Pink So
Jupiter over here
and we've been we've known for a long
time since Point array in I think 1906
that if I have three bodies so this is
the two body problem these are just
going to go around in kind of keplerian
uh ellipses right orbits with each other
but if I had a third body then the
Dynamics of that system may be chaotic
that might be kind of unpredictable and
chaotic if I add even a third body here
and that third body could be small it
could be an asteroid it could be a
satellite it could be a spacecraft in
fact we have chaotic transport of
asteroids in the solar system right now
which is interesting
and it turns out
that there are these very very special
saddle fixed points that exist in this
planetary system in this in this two
body problem there is a there is a
saddle point here and there is a saddle
point here uh and these are called the
LaGrange points the L1 and L2 LaGrange
points there's an L3 an L4 and an L5
there's five LaGrange points for for
this system but these two have a very
special property of having at least one
degree of Freedom that behaves like a
saddle
um one last thing I need to draw here is
that there is a kind of a potential
energy forbidden region uh in this
system so if I was an asteroid or if I
was a spacecraft and I only had a
certain amount of energy of kind of
kinetic energy
there would be a region that I couldn't
access I couldn't I could not occupy
this region because I don't have enough
energy
actually a really good thing because
this that a lot of asteroids from the
outer solar system Beyond Jupiter don't
have enough energy
to kind of get into the inner solar
system and so Jupiter is actually acting
like a referee or a goalkeeper for
Asteroids for the inner planet so it's
protecting us on Earth from outside
objects coming in and just creaming us
okay and so the only way that objects
can actually come into the inner solar
system the kind of the the asteroid is
the third body in this three body
problem so the sun is the massive one
Jupiter is also pretty massive and then
the third body we assume to be massless
but influenced by these and that's a
chaotic dynamical system
so a
like an asteroid the only way it can
come in is around these saddle points
there are these very special orbits that
will take objects into and out of the
inner solar system through this kind of
Jupiter Transit sometimes this is called
a Turn Style but really Jupiter and
these saddle points is mediating most of
the structure of Transport between the
inner solar system and the outer solar
system which is really really cool I'm
pretty sure researchers have found in
the last few decades there is an
extremely high proportion of what are
called twin asteroids asteroids that are
in kind of a binary orbit with each
other just moving around in each other's
gravitational orbits in the inner solar
system and we believe that it's because
they have to pass through this kind of
gravitational Turn Style and go really
close to Jupiter so all of the asteroids
that make it in kind of get bunched up
here
and they start to orbit each other and
they stay orbiting each other in here
which is really really interesting
estimates some estimates are that like
10 of them are paired up through these
turn Styles that's wild
um but what I really wanted to to point
out is that you know it's not just the
sun in Jupiter every pair of kind of
primary bodies has this structure so
um the Earth and the Moon
also have these saddle points this fixed
Point's really easy to understand this
this fixed Point uh here and here is
really easy to understand that's the
equal gravity point where if I'm right
you know there's a sweet spot between
the Earth and the moon where their
gravitational pull is exactly equal and
if I was right there I'd stay there
forever but if I move a little towards
the moon I'll fall into the moon's orbit
and if I move a little towards the Earth
I'll get sucked into the Earth that's a
fixed point that has an unstable
Direction obviously that's one of these
L1 points I think that's
I think that's L1 and this is L2
and
so so these guys also have those those
saddle points we just sent the James
Webb Space Telescope to live right
around this L2 Point
um is that right
no not this L2 point a different L2
Point um so the Earth and the moon have
one
um
the Sun and the Earth also have these so
kind of every primary pair the sun in
Jupiter has these points the Sun and the
Earth has these points the earth and its
Moon
has these points and so what's really
interesting is that these Saddles allow
me to transition in very energy
efficient efficient ways around the
solar system so for example if I'm on
one side of this saddle I can push
myself a little bit and go into the
inner solar system and if I push myself
a little bit on the other direction I'm
going to go to the outer solar system so
these fixed points are very very
important for energy efficient transport
in the solar system if we want to design
a space mission for example that goes to
all of the moons of Jupiter
we can do that with very little energy
by looking at all of the the fixed
points of each of the Jupiter moon
systems each of these fixed points for
Jupiter and its Moon and we can find
kind of orbits that get close to other
fixed points of other moons and connect
those together with really small amounts
of energy burn
and so uh it's really interesting that
the the skeleton of our solar system is
built out of these saddle points and the
orbits that emanate from those saddle
points and that kind of connects the
solar system in uh this kind of you know
freeway network of really energy
efficient transport and it organizes all
of the trajectories in the solar system
very non-linear system
um you know hugely non-linear it's
really this f of x is very non-linear
for the solar system very chaotic but
there exists these fixed points where
locally for a small radius they have
these saddle Dynamics that's
um kind of the the upshot here I want to
I want to get across good
um
yeah so so we can use those for energy
efficient transportation in the solar
system it's also how Jupiter protects us
from uh
from uh you know objects coming into the
inner solar system and I I think the
last thing I wanted to tell you I
believe it's the Sun
Earth system I think that what we did is
we put
the James Webb Space Telescope in what's
called a Halo orbit around the sun earth
L2 point
because this is super cool so a Halo
orbit it's because it looks like a Halo
like a like an angel's Halo and it
blocks the light from the Sun so this is
kind of protected from the light from
the sun
by the Earth and so it's always in the
shadow of the earth which means that it
has a lot better sensitivity for its
detectors it's not being bombarded by
sunlight so it can look out at all of
the stars out there without getting
contaminated by all of this
electromagnetic spectrum I think it must
be the sun earth L2 put in the comments
if I'm mistaken but this just you know
launched we've been waiting for this in
my you know I've been waiting for this
for for well over 10 years to happen it
just happened we just got images back
and it's amazing you know the power of
Saddle points in in the solar system
okay
um next lecture I'm going to tell you
what happens when these have complex
eigenvalues that's going to be super
interesting and we're going to use
Euler's formula to take e to the Lambda
T's and break that into Sines and
cosines when that Lambda is complex so
that's all coming up next thank you
[Music]